For your knowledge that it is funny what is related to contemporary neuroscience
Competent to recognize that it is considered a closed philosophy. It's really
They often make fundamental philosophical assumptions. I mean they take
Certain philosophical ideas as Muslim are often used as empirical information
Simply to revive old debates. For example, one of the basic shapes of images
Which I think comes to people's minds about the neuroscience that is relevant to the realization that the world
It is within our heads of reason that makes the world that what we are experiencing here is not me
I face you. I can not see you. I am testing something in my mind
On the form of a style of stimulation. Let me turn to the nature of colors as an example
To try to clarify what is in my mind and the idea of ​​this wonderful area where
Both science and philosophy decided to cooperate with each other and engage in dialogue
With each other and in many cases was a senior philosopher and also a senior scientist
Think about it. The point of view is that color, is a property of the surfaces of objects
, Is not the property that we naively believe we see but perhaps something like portability
Absorption and reversing light have certain wavelengths and produce a type of so-called b
Spectral reflection, but the color is on the surface.
Another point of view is that it is illusory to believe that color is something that exists in matter, that color is just an effect
Like the effect of the same thing on us. From that point the color happens to us. tree leaves
Not green. Greenness is just an event. For me it is a kind of sensation
Which is produced by the interaction of my nervous system with those leaves
My personal view is that both theories are wrong. I support the theory that color is
What you can call an environmental property means that color is a property produced by a method
Light interaction with surfaces. That is not meant to be a surface
The actual sheet is green. Its greenness is how it behaves with regard to light
So we think the light has one pattern, but of course it looks in a certain way under a certain light
If you take it out it will look different and if you convert it in certain ways it will be there
Shiny patches and a bright, bright spot on the surfaces of things
Which in sum are part of the true color of the thing. For me colors like shapes. Such as that of a three-dimensional shape
It has a hidden back side so the colors will appear in hidden ways if circumstances are present
Lighting changed. The problem of skepticism concerning the world
The outer, how we know things are what they really look like, how we come to know that
The argument that reliable sensory experiments are just teaser. Is a frequent philosophical teaser
I can not give it to you right now, nor can neuroscience solve it, but what I would like to do
I convinced you that neuroscience took a solution or at least
A position towards this repeated humor as a recognized thing and most neuroscientists who work
On the side of consciousness they assumed that experience is something that happens inside me. Something subjective. Something invisible.
The world we know is not beyond surfaces
Our tent. Beyond our direct knowledge because all we know at any time is the way it is
Our nervous system is stimulated by stimulation, which causes stimulation to always make us behind
Directed / produced by Jonathan Fowler
And Elizabeth Rhode
}